[Musica]
[Applauso]
un po di tempo fa avevo deciso di dare
un taglio netto alle abitudini della mia
vita sono uno che lavora sempre non ha
non ha altri tipi di interessi relazioni
non aveva tempo libero così deciso con i
miei due migliori amici di di fare un
viaggio un viaggio in giro per il mondo
e ci imbattiamo per caso su internet in
un forum che parlava di un viaggio di
una gara chiamata mongol rally
ecco il mondo rally è qualcosa di
assurdo è innanzitutto perché totalmente
senza senso
poi perché è considerata e lo potete
trovare su wikipedia come la gara più
folle insensata e pericolosa del mondo
ci sembrava perfetta per i nostri stili
di vita in più che non avevo mai dormito
in una tenda di campeggio non avevo mai
ero la persona più schizzinosa del mondo
quindi era proprio l'ideale andare
dall'altra parte del mondo a fare un
viaggio simile
e così decidiamo di partire un viaggio
di 20.000 km circa per oltre 20 paesi
tra cui qualche deserto un po di
dittature forse pure qualche guerra
sopra di noi in questo viaggio ogni anno
si parte da un punto diverso
l'anno nuovo che siamo partiti noi siamo
partiti da da un posto vicino praga
siamo partiti inoltre in oltre mille
persone
eravamo più di 200 team da tutto il
mondo noi rappresentavamo il nostro il
nostro paese l'italia e quando siamo
partiti ci hanno detto che c'erano
soltanto tre regole per affrontare
questo viaggio prima regola dovevi avere
un'automobile perché il viaggio si
faceva in automobile un'automobile che
avesse meno di 1200 di cilindrata e più
di dieci anni di vita del tipo dovevano
essere sicuri che ti saresti ammazzato
durante la strada
seconda regola era per beneficenza
quindi era obbligato per fortuna a
donare un importo in in beneficenza del
tipo se vogliamo noi lasciamo qualcosa
di bello a qualcun altro
terza regola non c'è nessun tipo di
assistenza né tecnica né sanitaria non
si possono utilizzare satellitari mappe
niente deve arrivare alla fine se non
arrivi alla fine non ti veniamo a
cercare quindi proprio alla andiamo così
alla deriva e che succede succede che il
nido il nostro team doveva essere di
quattro persone poi
la quarta persona luca non non poteva
venire ma voleva esserci a tutti i costi
così alla brillante idea di mandarci il
suo cartonato partiamo così in quattro
persone di cui una era un cartonato e vi
assicuro che arrivare con un cartonato
dall'altra parte del mondo è più
difficile che arrivare con luca vero che
questo è stato uno dei primi problemi
arriviamo sul luogo della partenza e ci
troviamo di fronte al nostro primo muro
ci troviamo di fronte a un controllo di
confine perché perché la partenza era un
campo militare finta ovviamente
scenografico in cui si ipotizzava un
3000 un anno 3 milano 3000 in cui la
tecnologia avrebbe distrutto l'umanità è
un manipolo di esseri umani era rimasto
si stava ribellando e stava cercando di
rifondare l'umanità quindi l'idea era
che noi eravamo barricati dentro questo
campo e dovevamo combattere per
sopravvivere e poi pannelli partiva il
mondo rally la storia era molto carina
unica cosa mi sono stupito di vedere che
nel 3000 per quanto si possa essere
stato nessun estinzione tecnologica o
altro ancora stavamo lì a parlare di
muri di confini territoriali sia ormai
confini territoriali diciamocelo non
servono più a nulla
io penso che solo le monete sono stati
sono rimaste legate ai confini
territoriali che se vado in giappone
deve usare lo yen
in america il dollaro e quel euro io mi
metto in un futuro in cui confini siano
solo funzionali cioè se devo utilizzare
un bene rifugio ho bisogno di un bene
rifugio utilizzerò probabilmente bitcoin
ma se devo utilizzare la mia auto
utilizzerò la tecnologia di dietro ai
ota o altri tipi di tecnologie che oggi
ancora non conosciamo bene ma che
sicuramente ci aiuteranno in futuro
comunque da lì dovevamo capire visto che
i libri si leggono della copertina
da lì dovevamo capire che il viaggio non
sarebbe andato tanto bene appena
entriamo ci accoglie un tizio con un
giubbotto catarifrangente un bazooka in
mano che che ci indica la strada ma non
era l'unico tizio strano poco più avanti
incrociamo una bellissima signorina che
e mentre molti di voi saranno guardando
il sedere a questa bellissima signorina
vi farei notare la mano mozzata che a
succedere che probabilmente appartiene a
chi prima di voi e ha provato a guardare
del sedere comunque il viaggio in
qualche modo parte e noi eravamo
carichissimi eravamo carichissimi perché
non vedevamo l'ora di vincerlo questo
viaggio perché noi l'avevamo fatto per
arrivare non solo fino al traguardo o
meno del 30 per cento ci arriva ma
l'avevamo fatto per vincerla questa gara
dovevamo distinguerci dovremmo farcela
ed eravamo talmente 4 menti i tre più un
cartonato talmente brillanti che per
forza avremmo vinto partiamo
dopo i primi 500 chilometri si rompe la
macchina il viaggio finisce disperati
invece che quattro persone di cui uno in
cartonato forse potevamo partire in tre
imprenditori un meccanico probabilmente
avremmo avuto più successo cosa succede
però non ci abbattiamo ci trovavamo
eravamo riusciti ad arrivare in romania
in romania si sa ci sono molti meccanici
quindi non ci abbattiamo e riusciamo a
coinvolgere meccanici per riparare il
guasto
dopo centinaia di euro spese e dopo
quattro giorni a cercare il guasto e vi
assicuro che erano venuti i maggiori
esperti del paese anche dalle campagne
erano venuti per aiutarci dopo quattro
giorni pezzi a cercare il guasto il
guasto non si trova avevamo buttato una
marea di soldi cosa facciamo prendiamo
il telefono apriamo youtube cerchiamo un
tutorial su come l'ha fatta la nostra ma
la nostra macchina il nostro modello di
macchina riusciamo a capire da questo
tutorial come smontare il serbatoio è
dentro al serbatoio in cui nessuno aveva
guardato troviamo un pezzetto di
plastica che aveva augurato tutto il
serbatoio d'aria per questo che la
macchina non andava avanti
qui abbiamo avuto la seconda lezione di
vita da questo mondo rally
abbiamo capito in quel momento noi aveva
mondiale il cui insegnati segnavamo
tutte le lezioni di vita durante il
viaggio in quel momento abbiamo capito
che poi essere esperto quanto di pare ma
c'è sempre un video tutorial di youtube
che ti fregherà ed eva è stata una
lezione molto importante che è successo
siamo riusciti a ripartire dopo la
romania ma prima di ripartire ci siamo
fermati in un autogrill e per andare in
bagno ci scappava
dovevamo andarci in questa top 1000 cc
accorgiamo subito mentre stavamo nel vc
che era era sporco e vuol dire dubbio
che schifo perché questo pazzo ha messo
una foto di un bagno sporco perché
realtà non era sporco in realtà quella
mosca non è vera quella mosca e
disegnata perché qualcuno ha pensato in
un cartello con scritto non sporcare non
lo ascolta nessuno ma se disegni una
mosca magari qualcuno la mira e la fa
dentro
ecco è questa è stata un'altra lezione
subito la romania ci ha dato un sacco di
elezioni un'altra lezione cioè spesso
quello che noi a prima vista definiamo
sporco in realtà non solo è più
intelligenti di noi ma anche molto più
pulito
siamo riusciti ad uscire da questo bagno
e siamo abbiamo oltrepassato qualche
altro paese arriviamo in turchia la
turchia bellissima però prima della
turchia al confine c'è una strada tra
romania e turchia che si chiama trans
gara samb è considerata la strada più
bella del mondo
ovviamente questa foto l'ho presa da
internet perché la foto mi era un po più
nuvolosa e quelle nuvole dovevano farmi
capire che avremmo avuto dei problemi
perché a metà montagna a metà strada
quando eravamo troppo avanti per tornare
indietro troppo indietro per andare
avanti
un acquazzone ma che dico appassione una
grandinata ci coglie di sorpresa e ci
sommerge d'acqua non si vedeva nulla era
buio pesto non potevamo muoverci
mettiamo la mattina di paro e per pura
fortuna riusciamo a trovare una casetta
sembrava anche abbandonata in questa
casetta riusciamo a trovare una persona
che ci ospita ci mettiamo a dormire non
siamo riusciti a dormire neanche un
secondo per tutta la notte perché c'era
un rumore scrosciante di acqua sembrava
che una cascata ci stesse entrando
dentro dentro la camera avevamo una
paura cane non riuscivamo a dormire la
mattina dopo ci svegliamo ci siamo
accorti che era una cascata che ci stava
entrando nella camera perché noi avevamo
trovato rifugio in un posto meraviglioso
sopra un lago accanto ad una cascata è
stato uno dei posti più belli della mia
vita che abbia mai visto e un'altra in
un'altra lezione della vita ce la stava
insegnando che quando ti sembra tutto
perduto anche nel buio più totale se tu
vai avanti arriva sempre qualcosa che
che non dia spot che non ti aspetti
probabilmente non saremmo mai stati in
grado di vedere di vedere questo
meraviglioso posto se non avessimo
incontrato quella grandinata superiamo
la romania e vi dico il rischio entrare
finalmente in turchia la turchia è
bellissima e ci accoglie con un deserto
bianco immaginativo 80 chilometri di
strada con questo deserto bianco accanto
e voi che che tutto il tempo di tema che
facciamo c'entriamo con la macchina dai
cioè è un sogno entrare nel deserto
anche la macchina con la bandiera
dell'italia sul tettino no il classico
sogno da da italiani ea un certo punto
immaginate la poesia i turchi chiamano
questo deserto bianco lago salato
già solo per la poesia e romanticismo di
questo nome dobbiamo entrarci dentro
entriamo dentro e scopriamo che il
deserto bianco chiamato lago salato in
realtà era un lago vero la macchina
inizia ad affondare nelle sabbie mobili
siamo perduti e da lontano vediamo le
persone passate farci foto e e sorridere
io immagino ancora coi pensieri dire
questi italiani sono proprio cretini ad
essere entrati nel lago salato e non li
biasimo assolutamente insomma a questo
punto avevamo appena imparato la lezione
dalla romania
anche nei momenti più disperati qualcosa
di nuovo appare iniziamo incamminarci
mentre il sole cocente imbatteva sul
sale quindi rifletteva ancora di più
sulla nostra pelle che si stava suonando
iniziamo a incamminarsi in questo
deserto per cercare aiuto e arriva una
cosa inaspettata nel nulla nel pieno
lago salato una sedia che non c'entrava
niente una poltrona totalmente ricoperta
di sale a questo punto non ci resta che
rimanere fermi ad aspettare qualcuno
arriva arriva un carretto della frutta
che riesce ad agganciare la nostra
macchina tirarci fuori abbiamo capito e
quindi casetti della frutta a bordo
strada qualcosa servono veramente
andiamo avanti riusciamo a superare con
non poca difficoltà questo questo
episodio è superata la turchia arriviamo
in iran in iran non ci resta che andare
al sud e vedere per secoli uno degli
imperi più grandiosi che l'umanità abbia
mai avuto volevamo vedere la città che
ospitava quell'impero e per andare a per
secoli abbiamo scoperto che sembra così
tanto assurda prima o poi devi ritornare
così tanto a nord e in quella strada la
macchina si rompe un'altra volta ma
stavolta per non perdere ulteriore tempo
claudio fabiano gli amici con cui ero
erano diventati esperti meccanici e
quindi decisero di seguire da vicino i
lavori perché volevano essere sicuri che
in poche ore si potesse risolvere il
problema ecco il problema si risolve in
cinque giorni
il fatto è che non stavamo in europa
stavamo in iran il visto stava scadendo
noi non avevamo più soldi per che dire
non ci sono banche internazionali non
c'è modo di di ottenere il tuo denaro
dall altra parte del mondo
entri con i soldi che cambi e quelli di
devono bastare
non solo ci stava finendo il visto ma
c'erano finiti i soldi non avevamo soldi
né per pagare l'albergo che ci ospitava
anche per mettere benzina e continuare
il nostro viaggio mi viene in mente una
cosa mi viene in mente una storia che ho
studiato quando stavo studiando la blog
chain e che uno dei una delle prime
transazioni intercontinentali in bitcoin
è avvenuta in iran perché una donna per
salvare sua figlia in america ha inviato
di bitcoin perché non poteva inviare di
dollari allora dico siamo salvi ragazzi
pio o del bitcoin bastato contattare
qualcuno su internet ed è fatta
cerchiamo su internet qualcuno di
bitcoin è l'unico con debiti quale stava
teheran e che era comunque 400 km non
potevamo arrivarci lo risolviamo il
problema ma non vi dico come perché
questa è stata la lezione più bella del
viaggio e ve la dico solo alla fine
fidatevi di me il problema l'abbiamo
risolto e siamo andati avanti e superato
l'iran riusciamo ad entrare in
kirghizistan
i dirigenti stanno un po su un posto
bellissimo l'unica cosa se leggete un
cartello con scritto scorciatoia
attenzione perché quella strada potrebbe
diventare un fiume che a sua volta
potrebbe diventare un letto di pietre e
a sua volta potrebbe costringervi a
raccattare dei degli alberi per cercare
di costruire dei ponti però ce l'abbiamo
fatta siamo usciti da questa strada e
abbiamo scoperto un'altra cosa che c'è
una cosa più importante dei muri i ponti
e che costruendo ponti si riescono a
superare i muri e allora questa è stata
un'altra lezione di vita importantissima
usciti dal kirghizistan abbiamo iniziato
gli altri stan tagikistan e così via
arrivati in tagikistan tagikistan dei
paesaggi stupendi
facciamo una strada che è considerata la
strada più pericolosa del mondo quella
di prima della giu della questa è la più
pericolosa si chiama pamir non è tanto
pericolosa per il fatto che sta in cima
ad un dirupo per circa 300 chilometri
questa è la parte più stime piace ve
l'assicuro
ma per il fatto che questa strada è un
confine naturale tra tagikistan
afghanistan e pakistan
quindi se poco poco di fermi a farti una
foto da scemo come ho fatto io non sai
che rischi di beccare un po di sì se un
po di talebani o al massimo qualche
tagiko che raccoglie la marijuana che
cresce per strada quindi e risale in
macchina e te ne vai
il fatto è che la strada totalmente
vuota e allora ci siamo detti ma
possibile che una strada così bella
pericolosa perché la roma sia vuota che
non ci siano turisti e per km e km
abbiamo fatto questa strada totalmente
vuota solo una persona abbiamo
incontrato un poliziotto seduto su una
sedia nel bel mezzo del nulla che appena
ci ha visto arrivare ha iniziato a
urlare a farci dei gesti bruttissimi e
noi abbiamo pensato guarda questo che
razzista vede dei turisti arrivare
dall'altra parte del mondo per le
bellezze del suo posto di respinge così
ma questi non ce l'avranno mai il
turismo è questo che continuava a farci
lanciata a metà e tu dicevi angela tale
dobbiamo passato e lui continuava non
volendoci far passare dopo il sindaco la
croce ci continua a fare un segno col
mitra nel dio che ci vuole sparare
questo vedendo che non aveva le armi
vedendo non aveva nulla noi eravamo
arrivati fila sediamo in macchina
andiamo avanti
percorriamo altri km arriviamo alla
dogana arriva della dogana la dogana era
chiusa non ho mai visto una dogana
chiusa vi assicuro che la brutta brutta
impressione
cosa succede la dogana chiusa citofono
ha citofonato risponde qualcuno che
urlando il famoso giocata joe cada ci
dice col google translate che ci ha
salvato la vita ci dice che la strada
era chiusa e la dogana pure e noi ci
ricordiamo di quello che ci faceva così
e forse ci voleva dire la strada è
chiusa allora diciamo perché è chiusa
noi dobbiamo passare il confine mica
possiamo tornare indietro e lui ci dice
è chiusa perché c'è stato un attentato
dell'isis hanno ucciso cinque turisti e
stanno cercando turisti da uccidere sul
pa meta e ci siamo riportati del
poliziotto che diceva attentivi uccidono
quel poliziotto ci voleva aiutare allora
torniamo indietro di corsa e tornando
indietro rincontriamo quel poliziotto
che ci guarda come per dire voi siete
veramente stupidi voi italiani siete
veramente stupidi superiamo il
poliziotto ma grazie a questa vicenda
conosciamo un villaggio quando i
ragazzini che che correvano scalzi per
strada con un affetto incredibile ecco
in quel villaggio questi bambini per
giocare con noi noi noi ci accorgiamo di
avere fame non avevamo soldi locali non
sapevamo come fare questi bambini ci
portano da un alimentare improvvisata
della zona che vendeva dei biscotti
fatti a mano e del pane fatto a mano e
ci regalano il cibo abbiamo imparato
un'altra cosa che noi abbiamo tutto
tendiamo a non dare nulla ma chi non ha
nulla ti dà tutto senza batter ciglio e
quello che potevamo fare da italiani da
tirare fuori un pallone insegna del
calcio
giochiamo a calcio con loro e quando
segnavano esultavano come avessero vinto
la champions è visto che tipo una
squadra che la champions non la vincerà
mai
io vi assicuro che almeno una volta
nella vita la champions quel giorno l'ho
vinta andiamo avanti superiamo il
tagikistan con un po di difficoltà nel
chiedere indicazioni e riusciamo ad
arrivare in turkmenistan
me lo ricordo come una zona in cui ci
sta ci sono persone che cercano di
introdurre abiti sporchi abiti puliti e
abiti sporchi abiti lavanderia
biancheria mutande detersivi e non
capivamo perché la frontiera per il
turkmenistan mentre eravamo ricoperti di
mutante della gente dura undici ore di
perquisizione perché è molto difficile
avere permessi per entrare turkmenistan
riusciamo a entrare in turkmenistan
palazzi dorati e bellissimi e vuoti
perché il turkmenistan una dittatura il
dittatore ai palazzi d'oro ma la gente
vive nelle baraccopoli nel deserto e
scopriamo il perché la gente portava la
biancheria perché di lavare 8 un paio di
mutande costa 155 dollari ci hanno un po
di legge tasse strane quindi diamo
questi 155 dollari ma ce ne andiamo con
le mutande pulite
prima di andarsene con le mutande pulite
scopriamo grazie ad una persona del
luogo che potevamo fare affari
perché un dollaro equivaleva a 3
5 manhatta turkmeni ma in realtà sul
luogo se andavi nelle baraccopoli in
cambio di un dollaro perché avevano
bisogno di quel dollaro tentavano 20th
moneta locale sei volte tanto dei geni
prendiamo questa persona andiamo in
banca prendiamo i nostri dollari
ricambiamo con turkmeni ritorniamo in
ballo in banca e rilievi cambiamo in
dollari e siamo ricchi diventiamo iren
del turkmenistan
questa è la foto prima di entrare in
banca con il nostro nuovo socio che
vedete lì questa è la foto dopo che
l'hanno arrestato
questa questa persona probabilmente
sapeva che sarebbe andato male potevamo
vedere dalla sua faccia finisce il sogno
e scopriamo un altro importantissima
lezione che è meglio essere liberi di
essere ricchi ve l'assicuro andiamo
avanti superato il turkmenistan
finalmente riusciamo ad arrivare in
mongolia che ci accoglie con un alba
stupenda grazie e questi netto arrivati
e mongolia arriviamo al traguardo è
arrivati al traguardo non mi resta che
raccontarvi la lezione più bella della
vita vi ricordate mirande che non sapevo
come salvarmi
mi chiamo a mia madre mi chiama mia
madre mi diceva perché stai fermo lì mi
seguiva da lontano con un comun già
localizzatore le mamme ma perché stai
fermo è perché ci sta scadendo il visto
non abbiamo soldi nella madre attacca e
la domenica mattina va nell'ambasciata
iraniana in italia inizia ad attaccarsi
al citofono non c'era nessuno perché la
domenica trova l'abitazione del
consolato del console iraniano
inizia a urlargli contro dalla strada
che suo figlio stava in iran e che
doveva liberarlo beh non so che ha fatto
mia madre ma qualcuno del governo
iraniano ha chiamato l'albergatore che
ci stava ospitando e l'ha obbligato a
non farci saldare il conto e regalarci
20 milioni di rial iraniani che sono
circa 2 300 dollari per uscire dalla ci
siamo salvati così allora la lezione più
importante è che puoi andare ovunque poi
essere intelligente quanto di varie può
avere i soldi che ti pare ma quando ti
serve qualcuno che ti salvi davvero dai
guai
ci pensa sempre la mamma grazie mamma ti
amo
[Applauso]